Bonjour Wilfried Franck merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt France
qu'en est-il de la situation dans les
prisons on a pas entendu beaucoup
l'exécutif s'exprimer à ce sujet
alors avant toute chose moi je voudrais
à nouveau souligner le professionnalisme
et le dévouement des personnel
pénitentiaire parce que ça fait
maintenant bientôt 2 ans a qui font
passe à cette crise sanitaire qui
perdure et malgré cela il continue de
donner un os niveau de service public
donc ils peuvent être fier de fière de
et bravo à toutes et à tous qui vend
l'exécutif l'exécutif et un pot
silencieux alors la direction de
l'administration pénitentiaire
aujourd'hui reste étrangement malgré les
annonces qui ont été fait par le premier
ministre
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
on a entendu des alertes un notamment de
la part des syndicats pardon de
dysfonctionnement possible à venir
pourquoi
il est évident que sans personnel point
de service public donc ça il faut que
nos dirigeants garde ça à l'esprit
lorsque on va se retrouver dans des
effectifs plus que réduit parce que
finalement les personnes elles sont tout
aussi susceptible d'être contaminé où
aucun contact que les autres donc
effectivement on va partir du moment où
vous avez moins de personnel à
l'intérieur des structures vous avez -
possibilité de gérer le quotidien des
pigeons
qui sont également contaminés or c'est
une population jeune c'est ce qu'a dit
le le gouvernement donc moins moins
enclin à faire des formes grave est-ce
que ça ça justifie peut-être le fait que
le gouvernement ne s'en préoccupe pas
tant que ça
disons qu'aujourd'hui le
représentant de l'administration
pénitentiaire attendre des directives
politique qui ne viennent pas et comme
nos politiques considère que l'activité
économique reste ouverte elle vient dès
lors on ne prend pas de restriction pour
milieu carcéral on sait très bien par
expérience depuis 2 ans
un établissement est considéré comme
étant avec le store il est évident que
derrière sa demande une question très
particulière déblocage de mouvement
déblocage de parloir déblocage
d'activité on a des personnels en moins
donc tu es aussi également la sécurité à
la fois des personnels à la structure en
jeu donc un autre sens il est grand
temps d'anticiper les choses plutôt que
d'avoir à gérer les difficultés
au niveau national
non c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
les difficultés sont gérés effectivement
localement c'est-à-dire que les chefs
d'établissement
compagnie des direction interrégionale
en compagnie de CRS et des préfets en
fonction de la situation sanitaire local
donc nous ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui
c'est que notre administration
réfléchis pas un plan peut-être beaucoup
plus globale pour pouvoir aujourd'hui
de la vaccination en milieu carcéral
concernant les évidemment les les
gardiens pénitencier mais également les
détenus sont-ils soumis à cette
obligation
que la population
concernant les personnes qui sont amenés
à venir en
consultation de soins au niveau des
unités hospitalier spécialisé pour le
reste il n'y a aucune obligation
vaccinale pour eux la population même
chose donc on a pas véritablement de
chiffres concernant le taux de
vaccination temps chez les personnel que
chez les détenus campagne il y a pas de
de vaccination dans les dans les centre
pénitencier
des proposer la vaccination sert qu'à
partir du moment où quelqu'un souhaite
se faire vacciner qu'un détenu soit cela
se faire vacciner tu t'es mise en œuvre
pour qu'il puisse l'être et pour les
personnels également vous demander quoi
concrètement au gouvernement
finalement de c'est-à-dire à la fois
remettre en place les dispositifs de
séparation au niveau des qui était
au strict minimum et également au niveau
des personnels bénéficiant des masques
FFP2 puisque a priori il semble être
beaucoup plus efficace puisque beaucoup
plus filtrant et également les mesures
concernant le télétravail pour
l'ensemble des personnels dans les
missions sont éligibles qui puisse en
bénéficier hauteur minimum de 3 jours et
donc pas ce que souhaite faire
aujourd'hui l'administration
pénitentiaire notamment avec les
personnels d'insertion et de probation
puisque ne seront limitées finalement
qu'à deux jours par semaine et non pas à
trois comme le souhaite au gouvernement
Wilfried Franck merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions en direct sur RT France